Interviews are a fantastic way
to improve your English
because you get to experience the language
spoken candidly [sincerely] and naturally.
In this lesson, you will learn with interviews
from the cast [actors] of Harry Potter:
Daniel Radcliffe (Harry),
Emma Watson (Hermione),
and Rupert Grint (Ron).
This is when from they
were filming the first movie.
Let's watch the first clip!
Hey, would you like to master Connected Speech?
Well, then you really should check out our
FLUENT WITH FRIENDS course!
You'll greatly improve your pronunciation and
comprehension with the full episodes
from the first two seasons of Friends!
And you can try it for FREE right now
with our 3-Part Mini-course
Just click up at the top or
down in the description below
to learn more and sign up.
So here at Learn English With TV Series,
every single week we help learners to understand
fast-speaking natives
WITHOUT getting lost,
WITHOUT missing the jokes,
and WITHOUT subtitles!
For example, João said that now when he travels,
he gets compliments on how great his English is.
So, if you want to improve your English fluency
just like João, be sure that Subscribe button,
and the bell down below so you
don't miss a single one of our new lessons!
Hey! Are you a Harry Potter fan?
Then you definitely are going to want to check out
this new playlist featuring
all of our lessons with Harry Potter.
Just click up at the top or
down in the description below to find that.
Remember that if you want to
take your fluency to the next level
we're really excited to help you!
The next step is to sign up for that
free 3-Part Mini-course
You could do that by clicking that button down below,
and, now it's time to go beyond the classroom,
and LIVE your English!
Aww Yeah!